so you've started a youtube channel
you've probably purchased all the gear
and you're
really just kind of stuck when it comes
to getting
started well what could be holding you
back is actually having confidence on
camera and i can so relate to this
because i waited
three whole years because i was scared
to get
on camera and i'm excited because we
decided to do a
two-part series here on the podcast
talking all about how to gain
confidence on camera if you're just
joining us for the first time
my name is heather torres and you are
listening to the think
marketing podcast we release a brand new
episode
every single tuesday so tuesday tuesday
so make sure you are subscribed wherever
you are consuming this content and yes
we are jumping into a two-part series
all about how to be confident on camera
we've got four tips for you in today's
episode
and four tips for you releasing next
tuesday so make sure you're subscribed
and ready for that episode
i love when we get to bring our industry
experts to the podcast for you and today
we have a fire episode with our friend
brock
johnson and this interview is actually
uh brought to you by idea to income dot
tips you can check out idea to income
dot tips
i'll tell you a little bit more about
that later but it's brock and chalene
johnson's
five day challenge on how to make money
online in 2021 well let's actually jump
into today's episode
where we're going deep into confidence
on camera
sean and brock have a great conversation
around
four main tips for building that
confidence so you can go live
you can make your reels your tik tok and
of course
your youtube videos so grab your
notebook lean in and let's jump into
today's episode welcome back to the
think marketing
podcast i'm fired up because in today's
episode i'm talking to
brock johnson a great friend and really
a expert in helping entrepreneurs and
content creators grow their brand their
influence and their income leveraging
instagram today though
we're gonna be talking about confidence
and the power of building your
confidence because whether you're gonna
be in a youtube video
on a video podcast and an instagram reel
or putting yourself
out there online you have to have
confidence you know brock has earned
six figures and built multiple six
figures in his business while playing
college football um and now does some
incredible projects with uh chalene
johnson who is also his mom and they run
a project like
uh instaclubhub and some very cool
things and so he's helped a lot of
different people
accomplish a lot of great results brock
welcome to the show
sean thanks for having me excited to be
here you know
i love this topic of confidence and
you've got these eight tips
because i would say for everybody
watching they may already feel like i
could skip this one but don't skip this
episode
because i think that you could always
grow in more confidence but at the same
time
we've gone through a lot of uh journeys
on our personally
where it's scary to get on camera we
recognize we don't have confidence i
remember back in 2010 when i shot my
first video
where i was comfortable being behind the
camera but i was afraid of trolls or
haters
or even being confident in my message so
i believe there's degrees to this
and i actually really believe that
people's most important account
is not their bank account it's not their
bitcoin
account although with bitcoin rising it
could be june
it's not it's not your dick's uh
sporting
goods rewards or nordstrom rewards or
bass pro shop rewards points account
your most important account is your
confidence account
because if you don't have confidence
you're always going to find a way to
lose
yeah if you don't have confidence you're
not going to create
your best content make bold moves
advance in your business so before we
get into these eight tips
brock what have you noticed with how
important confidence
is and in your own life i mean i feel
like you've been raised in a really
confident
family and you had a lot of confidence
instilled it to you uh but you also get
to coach a lot of people and
and what do you think the importance of
confidence and the need of confidence is
when it comes to content creators yeah
absolutely so i work with
tons of entrepreneurs on a daily basis
lots of coaching
direct one-on-one conversations where i
get to really understand
uh the root of a lot of these issues
that are holding people back from
growing whether it's on youtube or
instagram or even tick tock and we're
having these conversations
and ultimately one of the biggest
barriers preventing them from
consistently showing up
and creating the content that they know
that they need to create
and serving the audience that they know
they need to serve is they're lacking
the confidence to do so
whether that's the confidence to step
into their niche
the confidence to really start talking
about their expertise
the confidence to narrow in on one
specific topic that they're going to
be focusing on and not just you know
post about all things all the time for
all people which ultimately of course
will attract no one whether that's the
confidence to to go live
for the first time no matter what it is
it seems like it's always going back to
this
one issue of confidence versus fear the
confidence
to do what they know they need to do or
the fear that's that's holding them back
from doing it
that's so powerful and i'm excited to
get into these eight tips so brock what
is
number one so we can build our
confidence yeah absolutely so i think
that you
said the perfect word there which is
build and and my first tip
is practice you have to show yourself
that you can do the things that you want
to do and the only way to do that is to
practice
and i think that really tangibly there's
tons of opportunities on social media
to practice whatever it may be that you
that you want to get better at that you
want to feel more confident in doing
let's say sean that you want to get more
confident going live
on youtube but you already have some
youtube subscribers and so you don't
feel confident just flipping on live and
and
going live for your first ever youtube
live stream so instead
you can practice by going to another
platform where you either have less
followers or maybe a platform that you
haven't even
been on yet try experiment going on tick
tock and going live there going live on
instagram or
or experiment with twitter things like
that use these other platforms where you
might not have as big of a following
aka not as much pressure and use those
as opportunities to practice
and ultimately the more times you do
something the better you're going to get
at it like sean you started
with your first video recording in 2010
and i've seen that video
and we can look back and we can laugh at
it recently i've been looking back at
some of my
very early snapchat stories because i
practiced on snapchat
before i moved to instagram stories into
tick tock
and i i laugh at those because they're
so funny and they they sound like i'm
like a radio pod like a radio host and
totally
inorganic and inauthentic and not true
to me but they were practiced there were
opportunities to get better
and also i would recommend saving some
of your practice attempts because like
sean and i can tell you it's really
funny to look back a few years later and
say
this is where i started yeah it's all
about the journey
and your first videos are going to be
your worst videos and you have to be
willing to
start as our friend angie says poop your
pants scared
you got to just be able to just get on
camera sweaty armpits
and i love that you brought up
practicing on early snap
chats heather torres the host of the
think marketing podcast
um but she was terrified to get in
youtube videos she was terrified to get
on camera and also
kind of terrified to like create
long-form teaching content because she
didn't have the confidence for that yet
but what she did was she committed to
doing a
snap series every single day that had
like a beginning middle and
end and she didn't care about having
followers she didn't care
she hoped nobody else was watching she
was disciplining herself
to post consistent content that had a
lot more to do with her
than even with the viewer on the other
side and we
say hear a lot of think use your season
in obscurity
to prepare you for popularity use your
season when nobody knows you yet to not
be so worried about why am i not growing
or if i'm not getting the views yet
that's a huge
opportunity season that it's actually a
lot more about your personal development
it's a lot more about your practice
and science even reveals the confidence
competence
loop that actually psychology that
in order to grow in confidence you need
competence but the problem is when
you're just starting you don't really
have competence yet and you also don't
have confidence
yeah we just got to start you start
practicing and it's weird and it's
awkward
and then you start going oh that wasn't
too bad or wow i got a nice comment i
actually helped somebody
boost your confidence a little bit you
go back out next time and brock i love
that you're saying this because this
thing compounds
it builds i love that what's number two
yeah number two
is that you need to allow yourself space
to fail
and i think that a really tangible way
you can do this is literally
take out a pen and a piece of paper take
out a sticky note
and write yourself a permission slip a
permission slip today i'm going to allow
myself
to show up imperfectly on instagram
stories
today i'm going to allow myself to post
a facebook post
and not spell check it 15 times today
i'm going to give myself
permission to go live on youtube for the
first time whatever that thing
may be write yourself a permission slip
and the permission
is to be human the permission is to make
mistakes and have
imperfections and i'll let you in on
this the secret that really isn't a
secret
is that human beings especially now in
2021 sean and you know this
we are seeking out imperfections we
don't want this
fake photoshopped perfected super
polished
gleaming looking person on social media
because that's unattainable and that's
not something that we're going to
connect with i know myself personally if
i see someone who is
you know clearly that fake on social
there's no chance i'm going to follow
along and definitely there's no chance
i'm going to trust them
as an expert or someone who i can rely
on because
i know that they're not even being true
with who they are so
write yourself a permission slip and
allow yourself to be
imperfectly human so
so good i mean it's these sometimes i
feel like i'm a
walking vault of quotes and cliches but
fail forward sometimes you win sometimes
you learn it's not sometimes you lose
and every
video you post is an opportunity to fail
it's a permission step
to fail entrepreneurs i failed 10
000 times thomas edison but then i
finally found the one way
that worked and it's interesting
especially in the context of youtube
that when you look at some of the
biggest youtubers even pewdiepie
or mr beast they had hundreds of videos
under their belt before they broke
through before they got noticed
and for our community like a lot of
people aren't aspiring to be a mr beast
or pewdiepie
they're trying to help a particular
group of people they're mission-driven
purpose-driven entrepreneurs solving
specific problems
um but even still i mean man you just
need so much content under your belt
brock
how much content do you have under your
belt now
because even you're so confident you're
well spoken
but how much how many times have you
snapped instagram storied created
content posted videos and courses just
so far
and how old are you if i can blast that
out on the podcast
yeah absolutely so i am 23 years old and
i've been doing this
full-time for about four years or so now
i have hours probably days worth of
content on snapchat alone
i have hundreds of videos on
tick tock hundreds of videos and posts
and instagram pictures
over on instagram hours and hours and
hours worth of instagram stories
i currently am a co-host of a podcast
that releases
two episodes a week that are each like
30 minutes long but even before that
i did over a hundred episodes on a
podcast that was my own
so i have practice like we talked about
earlier over and over and over and over
again
there's more content that you could ever
watch in your lifetime and i've produced
that in just a few years because i've
allowed myself to to
fail forward as you said and to really
practice
listen think marketing podcast you got
to up your outputs um i love what brock
just said
um you know he's done so much volume and
he's got
i need to get him on youtube more but
he's got a bunch of youtube videos out
as well
and uh what's crazy is there's so much
volume to outputs
there and one of the things we've been
talking about earlier here at think
media
as we're in a new year is when you're
setting goals
set output driven goals not necessarily
even results driven goals
if if your goals are connected to
results well your confidence might be up
and down like wow people really clicked
on this video and liked it and people
didn't like this one
but if it's output driven your
confidence is man i checked the box
i got my weekly upload up i got my live
out i got the podcast out
and the the more outputs you can put out
actually really the quicker you will
grow
kind of makes sense if you go to the gym
one day
uh a month you the guns aren't going to
grow as fast that's my routine
i don't go to the gym but i i run too
much and chalene johnson always
is like dude i got to get you lifting
weights so you don't you know okay
whatever
but listen if if you go to the gym seven
days a week you're going to reach those
goals faster that confidence muster
muscle is going to grow a lot faster so
it's so powerful
to see that a level of volume and i want
to challenge you listening to this
up your outputs because they will help
you grow your confidence
faster hit us with number three brock
absolutely number three and i think
everyone knew this one was coming
was you can't compare yourself to others
there's this great quote you know
comparison is the thief of joy
and that's absolutely true if you are
thinking about yourself currently on
youtube
and comparing yourself to a mr beast or
a pewdiepie of course i think
every single one of us 99.999 of the
population
would feel defeated but you can't
compare your chapter 1 to someone else's
chapter 17.
someone else might be nearing the end of
the book or somewhere in the middle of
their book
and you're just getting served you're
just sitting down at the laptop
to start typing your your intro your
chapter one so
you can't compare yourself to other
people when you do that's a one-way
ticket
to a blow to your confidence and hurt to
your ego you start comparing yourself
why don't i look that pretty why don't i
sound that good
well guess what if you could see their
first video if you could listen to their
first podcast or
or read their first blog post you would
be laughing because chances are you
might actually even be better than that
but i think the only person who you can
really compare yourself to consistently
is who you were yesterday and if you're
incrementingly incrementally
one percent every single day getting
better than who you were yesterday
that's a safe comparison but do not for
all intents and purposes please avoid
comparing yourself to others i love that
brock and you know i think sometimes if
we're honest and i've been here as well
we could be afraid the thing that holds
us back from being confident sometimes
too
is is not only maybe comparing but being
afraid of starting late
and kind of being afraid of starting
small and being seen as
starting small yeah because uh
especially as some of these social media
platforms are now maturing
um you know we can feel like we're late
to the game and like
and so we get this question a lot should
i hide my subscriber number because you
can turn that on and off on youtube
because it's like i'm embarrassed of it
when i'm just starting
kind of but i want to encourage you
listening like
everybody started at zero there's
something powerful about the fact like
there's no need to actually hide your
subscriber number in my opinion don't
buy subscribers there's no need to
uh try to boost your followers up
there's something about the journey you
know now there's this new app called
clubhouse
and what's been interesting is i've been
seeing uh all these actually really
massive people
with like 100 followers because it's a
brand new app like it just happens to be
that some of these apps are are more
mature
but man comparison will will derail you
so quickly
it's blinders on get clear on your
mission who you called to serve what are
you trying to build what are you trying
to post and if you're output driven
you don't even have time to watch what
everybody else is doing you got to focus
on what you're doing
what you're building um i love that
brock all right what's next
next number four is to focus on your why
and if you don't already have your why
if you haven't clearly defined like
your why just think about it for a
minute maybe pause the podcast as you're
listening right now
and just think about what is my why why
do i do what i do what is my
driving focus is it financial freedom do
you want to change the world do you want
to provide for your family like what is
your why
and i think your why is going to far
outweigh the fear and i think that
ultimately that's what it comes down to
is
when we're feeling not confident and
when we're not
doing the things that we know we need to
do it's because
we're thinking about everything that
could go wrong and we're thinking about
the fear and we're thinking about the
potential haters and
the naysayers that exist on social media
but we're failing to remember our why
and we're also failing to remember the
the group of people
the hundreds if not thousands if not
millions of people
who need to hear our message and who
really deserve to be
served by us and who we can help and we
can change
lives but we have to take that first
step as we said earlier like you have to
just get started whether that's
your live stream or your first tweet or
your first instagram post whatever
that thing may be if you don't just get
started
and you can't remember your why and you
let all the the
potential negative outcomes keep you
from the
the positive outcomes that are likely to
follow
uh then you're never actually going to
get started so a great way to grow your
confidence
is to stay in your why and keep those
people
on the front of your mind brock what's
your why
and how do you how did you find it was
it immediately clear or have you kind of
been refining it i think that i've had a
few why's over my life and i kind of you
know keep them
in different stages of my mind but i
think that one that i've had almost my
entire life
is that i want to help as many people as
possible not to get too off subject
but i'm an enneagram too if anyone knows
about the enneagram the two
is nicknamed the helper i want to help
people so that's my wise i want to help
as many
people as possible when i was young
growing up i thought it was going to be
to be a professional football player and
i would use that outlet that platform
to help as many people as possible now
i've
changed to pivoted i do something else
rather than playing in the professional
football league
uh but i still have the the goal the why
of helping as many people as possible
and then on a personal level
i want to when i was in college create
financial freedom for myself so i didn't
have to rely on my parents i didn't have
to
uh have them paying for my meals and now
that i'm out of college and i'm starting
a family i want to be able to provide
for my family
and provide that financial stability so
that we can live the life we want to
live
man it's beautiful and ladies and
gentlemen brock johnson
is officially engaged is there a wedding
date happening is that a 2021 event
it's gonna be probably a 2022 event
we're waiting before we even are gonna
start planning we got some great advice
that uh you know we should just kind of
enjoy being engaged for a little bit
before we hop into planning so we're not
even starting planning for a couple more
weeks
well that's brilliant and of course
question of the day is man what's your
why
and so maybe think about that
rhetorically if you're on the podcast if
you're on the video podcast
drop it in the comments like like what
drives you
and that inspires me brock it's always
powerful to hear people what drives them
and it always whenever things get really
even overwhelming
and tiring and why am i even doing this
like you actually why am i doing this
like remember your why like
why am i putting this hard work why am i
editing
and and posting videos for results that
are
not outweighing the work at first um
reasons come first
results come second and having those
powerful reasons that can fuel you to
get through the hard
times these are essential in this
industry because there's going to be
times where you want to quit
where it seems like it's not working out
where you go up and make some progress
and it feels like you're going backwards
so remembering your why i love it well
that was
part one of our two-part series all
about how to be confident on camera we
went through those four tips today
practice have space to fail you can't
compare yourself to others and
focus on your why and man that last
part that brock and sean were talking
about your why it's so important and
really
i know it was tip number four but for me
it is the first thing i think about when
i'm trying to
to get over being comfortable on camera
even recording this podcast right now
i've already messed up four times i know
that i
am probably rushing through what i'm
saying but i've just learned that over
time
my why is gonna get me through this i
know that creating this content for you
for putting the camera on for getting
started for
just pushing through and understanding
that i know why i'm doing this
that is what helps me get through the
hard days and when i think about
you know having space to fail man i've
failed a lot when it comes to
creating videos and over time you just
kind of learn
that this is just like a friend the
camera becomes a friend
and that's who you're talking to on the
other side while your video might go
viral and millions of people will watch
it normally
you're really just talking to the one
person who's watching your videos
on their phone or on their tv or on
their computer right it's that
one-to-one connection
and so confidence for me on camera has
really come from
over time understanding that when i'm
looking at the lens
then i'm just talking to a friend and
that helps to eliminate
the anxiety that comes with public
speaking you know there was a study that
was done that said that
77 of people actually have
public speaking anxiety and i fall under
that category
for sure but knowing my why knowing that
i have space to fail
not comparing myself to others and
really just practicing over and over
that really is what helps me get through
creating videos for you
so i cannot wait for us to go into part
two
next week but your next step is to go to
idea to income dot
tips that is brock and chalene's five
day challenge that's going to be
starting soon so you want to make sure
you register for this five day challenge
speaking all about how to make money
online in 2021 i'm signed up and excited
locked in because brock and chalene and
brett are going to be teaching some
amazing tips
on how you can get started with an
online business
right now so if that sounds like your
next step you should go to
idea to income dot tips right now
now if you got value out of today's
podcast i want to invite you to
share this with a friend and one way
that you can do that
is by rating and reviewing the podcast
now this doesn't mean it goes directly
to your friends but it helps us to be
able to get this podcast out to more
people
just like you who want to learn how to
crush it on
youtube and when you rate and review the
podcast over on itunes
you might get a shout out on the podcast
and today's shout out goes to
steve from scranton steve says
think marketing is the best and provides
value content
each episode to help grow your business
thank you so much steve
for that review and if you haven't
shared this yet with a friend definitely
hit the share button
and get it out to someone who needs to
grow their
youtube channel well that was episode i
don't know what number but
part one of the
two-part series all about confidence on
camera join us
next week as we dive into four more tips
for you
all around how to gain more confidence
when it comes to creating your
videos i want to thank you so much for
your time and for being a part of our
think
community and make sure you go to idea
to income dot tips
if you want to join brock johnson
chalene johnson
and brett johnson all on their five day
challenge on how to make money
online in 2021 i'll see you on the next
episode
[Music]
you